The verdict is in: Mortal Kombat is a pretty
fun movie.
Critics and fans alike are praising it for
not taking itself or its story too seriously,
but even in that spirit, some aspects of its
story suffer from plot holes that can't easily
be brushed aside.
"Mortal Kombat" begins at a dire moment: Outworld
will invade if Earthrealm loses one more tournament.
At the same time, an ancient prophecy states
that Earthrealm will see new champions arise
"by the rise of Hanzo Hasashi's blood."
With this looming prophecy about Hanzo Hasashi's
bloodline, Outworld sorcerer Shang Tsung wants
to eliminate the remainder of Earthrealm's
warriors before the tournament so it isn't
possible for Earthrealm to win.
The only problem with that plan is that none
of it makes sense.
Shang Tsung's conversation with Mileena about
the plan is pretty telling — she worries
that Raiden may discover their breakage of
"rules set in stone by the Elder Gods," and
he responds that they didn't "win nine straight
tournaments by following the rules."
Later, when he invades Lord Raiden's temple
with Sub-Zero and Mileena, he is confronted
by Raiden, who notes that "It is forbidden
to claim victory until the tournament begins."
Shang Tsung replies with the assertion that
the other Gods will be, quote, "too lazy"
to stop him.
There are problems with this logic.
First, Shang Tsung acknowledges they've managed
to cheat enough to win nine times in a row
without thus far getting caught.
Why doubt their ability to do so now?
On the other hand, killing Earthrealm warriors
outside Mortal Kombat won't win the right
to invade Earthrealm.
Basically, Shang Tsung inexplicably takes
a much more complicated, brazen path towards
cheating than just fighting in the tournament
like he had before.
It's not like his winning record needs the
help.
And if he's going to cheat anyway, why now?
Why not earlier, between tournaments when
Earth's marked defenders would be teenagers,
or even younger?
None of it quite adds up.
Liu Kang says that his charge is to gather
all the champions of Earth.
The trouble is that he's extremely bad at
his job.
We become aware through conversations between
Sonya and Cole that she and Jax had long been
aware of a number of marked champions.
We're also told that many of those champions
are dead, since Liu Kang notes "there are
not many of us with the markings left."
The series of events that brings our group
of champions together is due to Sub-Zero finding
Cole first, bringing him, Jax, and Sonya together
-- but not without first almost killing Jax
and Cole.
Meanwhile Cole, Sonya, and Kano make their
way towards the temple of Lord Raiden because
Sonya just happens to be part of a group who
has connected all these dots, and Kano happens
to know the location of Lord Raiden's temple.
When they get there — no thanks to Liu Kang
— he seems surprised to see them, saying,
"At last!
Finally, you have come to seek out Raiden's
temple."
Despite the apparent urgency of needing to
gather all the champions of Earth for an all-important
Tournament that's about a month away, Liu
Kang was seemingly content to just sit around
and wait on the off chance it all worked out.
For someone charged with bringing together
Earthrealm's champions, at no point did Liu
Kang find, bring, or train any champions.
Meanwhile, other marked champions seem to
be dying all the time, and we have no evidence
he intervened at any point to gather or protect
them.
The entire reason it all worked out is because
Cole was saved by Jax, shepherded by the unmarked
Sonya, and guided by the untrustworthy Kano
(who isn't even supposed to have the mark).
So If Liu Kang really is supposed to be gathering
the heroes of Earthrealm, he's absolutely
and completely terrible at it.
When Sonya Blade, Cole Young, and Kano arrive
at Lord Raiden's temple, Liu Kang and Kung
Lao immediately take to training them.
Cole, Kano, and Jax each have the dragon mark.
With Jax recovering from his minor arm injury,
the more experienced warriors take to training
Cole and Kano.
The issue: Kano from the get-go is a rough,
disrespectful, power-hungry narcissist with
a criminal background.
They train him with the rest of the warriors
until they discover his arcana — and he
easily becomes persuaded by Shang Tsung's
forces with the promise of more power.
He compromises the defenses of Lord Raiden's
temple, and engages the heroes in combat with
the arcana they helped him attain.
Here's the complication with training anyone
who enters the temple: warriors can absolutely
change sides and betray Earthrealm with their
powers, helping Outworld's conquest of the
realm.
With a small number of fighters, losing one
to the other side is a pretty big change in
the balance of forces.
Why, then, train literally anyone as soon
as they enter, especially if they seem like
a shady character?
When Sonya Blade meets Cole, the first thing
she wants to know is if he has the dragon
mark.
When she, Cole, and Kano arrive at Lord Raiden's
temple, they're reminded repeatedly how important
the marking is.
Raiden reinforces to Cole how without his
arcana — which one needs the Mark to get
— he's really of no use to the fight.
Liu Kang repeatedly reiterates how you're
a liability without being chosen and having
your Arcana.
Mileena even refuses to kill Sonya because,
without the mark, she has no value in the
scheme of the struggle between realms.
With all this in mind: why is Sonya even there?
She's a great character and a pivotal part
of the plot but, in terms of the story, it
doesn't make sense.
She's let into Raiden's temple, and though
Kung Lao does forbid her from actively training
with the others, she's still basically involved
with the entirety of the conflict with Shang
Tsung.
She's even pulled by Raiden into his void
to prepare for the team's final battle plan,
which happens before she duels Kano, kills
him, and finally gains the mark.
Given the rules that are continually reinforced,
and the strict messaging that people without
arcana are a liability, Sonya's deep involvement
with Raiden's group of warriors makes no sense.
When Cole meets Sonya, they have one strange
guest tied to a chair: Kano.
Sonya explains that he had just been caught
after killing the fate-chosen champion they'd
previously been looking for, thus securing
a mark for himself.
At this point, Jax had already gained a dragon
mark, but Sonya had not.
Regardless, Sonya knows through her research
the importance of the marks for signifying
Earth's champion defenders in the Mortal Kombat
tournament, and that the tournament is pivotal
in protecting Earthrealm.
She knows the stakes are high, that not having
a mark impedes her ability to fight for Earth.
And she also knows that killing a mark-bearer
transfers the mark to the victor.
Sonya had all this knowledge while maintaining
the upper hand on a criminal scumbag like
Kano who had just killed a champion of Earth.
Also, at this point, Sonya isn't aware that
he knows the location of Lord Raiden's temple.
There is no clear reason to keep him around
as a prisoner who killed one of Earth's champions,
especially when the stakes are so high and
he has the mark that would allow her to protect
the Earth instead of him.
Heroes are often written to avoid killing
out of some kind of personal moral code, but
this is "Mortal Kombat," and Sonya's background
as a soldier is a testament to her willingness
to kill threats when necessary.
With all of this in mind, capturing Kano rather
than taking his mark was an inexplicable choice
for her character to make.
Moreover, had she killed him, Earth would
have had one more champion against the apocalypse
— and one less enemy of humanity.
The new "Mortal Kombat" film introduces a
further innovation to the "MK" universe, beyond
the creation of Cole Young: arcana.
The dragon markings mean you're a chosen champion,
and chosen champions spend the movie struggling
to activate their arcana: in other words,
their unique power.
Arcana is unique to the individual — it
can be Kano's laser eye, Liu Kang's fire powers,
Cole's brass armor and weapons, or something
else entirely.
It's unpredictable, powerful ... and woefully
unclear.
Liu Kang informs Kano, Cole, and Sonya of
the importance of having a marking and finding
your personal arcana.
As he explains to everyone, "If you fail to
discover your inner power, you will never
defeat your opponent."
He even directly addresses a comment to Sonya
-- but it's terribly unclear why he's even
talking to Sonya because she can't discover
her power and doesn't have a mark.
Later, Liu Kang clarifies that the fighters'
inner power comes from the arcana, and that
the point of their training is to unlock that
power.
How does that work?
Well, there's a variety of competing explanations.
He first explains that they'll discover their
arcana by training in the fight pit.
Later, he clarifies that the arcana's activation
must come from their soul, and whatever it
is that drives them.
Later still, he says that "Pain is the ultimate
catalyst" towards finding the arcana.
This all effectively means that the warriors'
arcanas all manifest in random and very individual
ways, making it seem like a pointless thing
to train for.
Liu Kang seems entirely convinced that arcana
manifests from pain in the process of training
in the pits, but that's not what activates
arcana for almost any character.
Cole's emerges from his daughter's strength
bracelet.
If she didn't make that, would his arcana
be entirely different?
Furthermore, the relationship between getting
the mark and getting the arcana is seemingly
random.
Liu Kang kills a child trafficker on assignment
and gets his arcana immediately in the process.
Sonya gets her mark and her arcana by killing
Kano.
Kano got his from his ego being wounded.
Cole is born with his mark and no fights nor
dangers activate his arcana until his family
is in danger.
Jax kills someone to get his mark ... and
doesn't get arcana until his arms are ripped
off, he's supernaturally given new arms, and
Sonya's endangered.
Why is the emergence so randomly timed, and
the form so arbitrary?
And why does Liu Kang think it's related to
fighting when it isn't?
As far as protectors of Earthrealm go, Raiden
is quite inconsistent.
In Hanzo Hasashi's life, Raiden doesn't intervene
when Bi-Han kills him, and he allows the assassin
to kill much of his family.
But then he shows up to collect Hanzo's infant
daughter to protect his lineage, and keeps
his kunai to facilitate Scorpion's later emergence
when Earthrealm needed it most.
Basically, Raiden continually asserts he's
"not allowed to intervene," despite the fact
that he keeps intervening anyway.
The biggest inconsistency, however, is when
Shang Tsung and his fighters arrive in Raiden's
temple in force, and Raiden essentially pauses
the fight to pull the Earthrealm defenders
into the void between realms.
Some of them, anyway.
Due to Sub-Zero and Shang Tsung's counterattacks,
he doesn't manage to immediately teleport
Cole or Kung Lao, the latter of whom gets
his soul gruesomely consumed by Shang Tsung.
Immediately afterwards, Liu Kang and Cole
are teleported away.
Jax asks Raiden why he couldn't save him,
to which Raiden replies, "Elder Gods are forbidden
from engaging in one realm's war against another
... it is my job to protect Earthrealm but
I cannot save every soul within it."
But he literally did just engage in the war
by teleporting people away to regroup, in
a tide-turning move that proves to be extremely
successful.
Raiden intervened so much that he managed
to save every other Earthrealm champion.
He even pulls Kung Lao's Razor-Rimmed Hat
into the teleportation lightning at the last
second, just not the warrior himself.
Poor guy.
"Flawless victory."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.